we live in an era where you can Channel
surf on YouTube and you land on somebody
who says the mainstream thinks this is
true The Establishment thinks this but
here's the actual truth you're all in on
that but why are you all in on that
there's something about the lone genius
that we want to snuggle up to them
rather than the faceless establishment
because that person is speaking
passionately we're blind to the
statistical representation of reality we
have people who exploit this ignorance
exquisitly and they're called Casino
owners they're exploiting the fact that
humans fundamentally do not understand
probability and statistics that Gap
manifests in adulthood with our
susceptibility to others who do know the
statistics who then exploit your
ignorance of it